well earlier this year we asked you to
tell us about outstanding women in our
community and we heard so many
incredible stories of sacrifice and
commitment and we've narrowed down that
pool of remarkable women to just four
that's tough because there are so many
here in the valley well this morning our
Denise Valdez tells us about Sean Murray
a mother who helped shape her son's
dream of giving dignity to foster
children and improving the lives of so
many others
you might want to put that okay sideways
for five years this mother and son have
incubated an idea into a meaningful
non-profit called clothes for kids she
wasn't right here none of any of this
would happen Nigel and Sean Murray still
remember the day a young foster child
arrived at their home with nothing more
than a garbage bag that moment changed
both their lives he's like Mom you know
I want to do something about this and so
we figured a way that we could help
these children have dignity is to at
least when they're going from house to
house they'd have a nicer bag just
something that simple you wouldn't think
that it mattered but it really does
matter that's how close for kids was
born this is our first haul and it
provides children and teens living in
foster care with duffel bags full of
clothes shoes and Necessities Sean is
the director Nigel the Visionary she was
there to kind of guide me along and
teach me how to handle all these adult
things while I'm 14 years old so far
they've touched the lives of nearly 4
000 foster kids from a humble beginning
of donated clothes
to now a house full of new wardrobe each
room dedicated to the age of the child
when you think of the value of this
child and the dignity and they're
already going through a hard time we
want to give them the best of the best
hey everybody Nigel and I while growing
the charity and navigating its future
the pair share a special bond we can
connect on a business level then after
we leave here you know what I mean we're
we're mom and son again so yeah that's
my business partner and my mom at the
same time although she's a biological
mother to one her mission is to love
serve and support as many children as
she can
when she discovered that a child who
can't read by the time they're in third
grade is more likely to go to prison she
launched a reading program I think if we
would pour generosity into our kids
empathy and compassion That's How we'll
see the world change
and making ordinary extraordinary
ordinary things every day just even in
the mundane you never strive to say hey
I'm going to do this today because it's
remarkable it's just there is Beauty in
the mundane we folded all the clothes
and we're putting them in the bag taking
mundane moments and making them
memorable I'm so happy clothes for kids
is able to be here with you and Sean
Murray dedicates herself to embracing
children empowering women elevating
community so this little guy is going to
get this blanket we are proud to
recognize her as a remarkable woman in
southern Nevada
Denise Valdez eight news now
remarkable wow yeah love that 641